how women will say women are oppressed
how
they say well I'm not going to sit here
and tell you if you don't know because
there's no answer for that how are women
oppressed tell me how in 2022 women are
oppressed I want a list put it give it
to me in list form they have nothing to
say all they have to say is that I was
told that they're oppressed I was told
we're oppressed there's no examples to
give and that is a problem and it gets
exposed over and over and over again now
you can say historically something used
to happen but you're talking about the
present honey you're talking about the
now in this moment women are not
oppressed today in the United States of
America that's not happening it's not
real it's not happening so there's going
to have to be a come to Jesus moment
with a lot of these young girls where
they realize that what they're being
told and what they're being feds
naturally